this is I've never done this before
you know welcome to another episode of
Tiger Valley I am your captain Bob and
you know what I feel good
Game of Thrones feel good after that
pretty good you know
I have my I have my doubts and have my
questions but other than that you know
not everything was fulfilled okay and
then um I'm gonna tell you guys a little
story we got George here we got what's
your name Joe Gilbert I call I love my
girlfriend [ __ ]
one right here a man from the country
now he's doing it for real okay a couple
of them like a month ago I got a call
saying that um this particular person
wanted to be on Tiger Bill I couldn't
[ __ ] believe that you know and I'll
tell you why because you know when I
destroy a man in ping-pong you know dude
it's like when I cuz I'm fat yeah and I
I don't exercise or you know see this
yeah this hurts that just lifting my arm
like this hurts
oh it's pain yeah it's a pain because I
just don't my body doesn't flow sure
okay calorie burn max is 68 68 oh wow
okay and that's just by blinking yeah
okay so when I you know what dude let
being fat right don't move right and I'm
being challenged by a white dude right
to ping-pong it's like blasphemy friend
it's like you want to judge Yeah right
how'd he go about it well here's the
deal all right so I played Santa Claus
at this 91x
concert in San Diego I did it become
that on the strength of the lineup mmm
my friend Mike goes al Jay I'm like okay
and he's like inner poggle yes I'll do
it right huh so I show up and I see
Billy Idol go up he looks a little
weathered but cuz I hear me like he's
been through it right yeah
and then I saw Interpol go up loved it
that was in the side I was you know yeah
I don't know it you know but I was
dancing burn I a Larese yeah and then
the lead singer Paul banks who's in the
room but you know more knowledge yeah he
just walks up to me he goes hey you play
ping-pong which is kind of racist this
is just my point of view and there yo-yo
you can defend yourself right look at
this [ __ ] guy rock star right so I
like the challenge alright where's the
ping-pong table yeah right and right and
he's pretty good though right he's not
Judah Friedlander or Frank Caliendo good
but well when I say it and they all
right that's the rule right so in my
head I'm like oh I'm gonna go 80% on
this right oh pretty good and then I in
my head I'm like go 90 you're gonna have
to go 90 right and you know I beat him I
think two games Wow - what did he win
again I know I barely buy yeah I did two
games right yeah I will add an important
piece of information
okay go ahead at the information now all
right after you anyway bragging about
all right so then I did that right and
then I looked him in the eyes I looked
in my eyes his face was like really
sweaty but probably on the show yeah you
know and I look at him and I got a
single bead of sweat we're building it
we're building it and we're building in
my head this is how I welcome I looked
at this guy New Yorker in the eyes right
and I went later dude right and you
could just see a man die in front of me
inside his just soul
I guess his soul just like cloud within
his eyeballs right and he probably wrote
a couple songs about it but anyway he's
the lead singer of one of my favorite
bands it's called Interpol right and
he's here
give a round of applause to Paul banks
everybody yeah go ahead Paul thank you
very much yeah good to see you
I don't I don't remember challenging
what I remember there was a the table
backstage right I think that's where we
were introduced was like next
the table yeah that's worse he wanted a
photo with you this is really how it
went down he didn't just walk up to you
and say do you play ping pong
you wanted a photo with him you begged
Mike Halloran to be like can we can you
please ask them if it's okay to take a
photo was it was it also at the it was
at that show with the Bowie with uh with
Billy Idol and well yeah I was it Tears
for Fears also played that yeah I
thought it was one of our shows like a
headlining show that we did that no it
was it was no it was I know that all J
played you and an idol but I don't
remember who else okay
it was like a Christmas you know did
that the Christmas show they do every
year yeah yeah oh yeah like a new New
Year's rockin Eve yeah something like
that yeah yeah I mean I remember I
remember the defeat and and funnily
enough like the other person that has
what my ass is Judah Friedlander
I've played Wow he [ __ ] destroyed me
he's so good yeah yeah I was really
impressed he's kind of like a
grandmaster
he's what did he like semi-pro right
he's like semi-pro hmm yeah that was at
Spin you know that oh you're in New York
yeah
[Music]